elles ne sont pas nombreuses au
parlement et les femmes fortes de
pouvoir sont encore plus rares le
conseil du statut de la femme a donc
écrit au premier ministre
en termes d'influencé ce qu'on a dit
c'est que les femmes ont moins d'influx
ans aujourd'hui au conseil des ministres
qu'elles en ont eues depuis plusieurs
années un recul dit elle alors que les
femmes n'occupent que huit places sur 25
le tiers du cabinet elle ajoute que ces
femmes ne sont pas très puissante
puisqu'elle gère athènes 9 % du budget
du québec
le premier ministre ne voulait pas
répondre à la question
mais d'autres l'ont fait à sa place
michel barrette monsieur police un boys
club dit elle avec une attitude
irrespectueuse à l'assemblée nationale
une attitude généralisée d'arrogance de
condescendance mais je voudrais que
c'est pire lorsqu'il s'adresse à dire à
des femmes la déclaration a déclenché
une spirale d'émotion mais elle me donne
un seul exemple mais elle parle
d'attitude a précisé un journaliste
vient changer de mode ratio là on n'est
plus dans le sexe et son nez dans
l'attitude
alors honnêtement aux objets de zéro
pour une personne qui était capable de
retarder des projets doit pendant deux
cents à arles
si on veut parler d'être sedan chambre
la corde sensible de la ministre
responsable de la condition féminine a
aussi été touché sa relation avec un
animateur de radio vient de faire la
manchette mais quand je regarde la
presse parlementaire
est-ce difficile pour une femme de faire
de la politique
si je pense à mon expérience du week-end
oui c'est sans compter qu'elle a des
enfants
comme plusieurs députés ont s'agit soit
en sièges des bâillons en sièges en
période intensive et c'est vrai pour
beaucoup de femmes qui quand ils ont des
enfants veulent coucher à la maison
le parlement est un milieu d'hommes le
conseil du statut de la femme pense
qu'il n'ya qu'une solution le
recrutement
il croit que les grands partis doivent
faire plus d'efforts pour s'assurer de
l'élection de plus de femmes c'est une
question de volonté politique ici martin
biron radio canada québec